It’s November 11th and in one week a copy of
the U.S. Constitution is going up for auction.
Everyone expects it to draw the usual crowd of
wealthy collectors, but the crypto community has
another plan. They want to crowdfund enough money
to place a winning bid, and they’ll do it using a
DAO. There’s only one week until the auction, so
they need to move fast. On Friday the 12th, they
put up a website. Things are messy, with competing
code repositories, but on Saturday, they find
some partners to help. Juicebox will help with
crowdfunding, SyndicateDAO will help with legal,
and FTX will help with exchange. The auction
house agrees to work with the DAO on Sunday,
but there’s a problem… Sotheby’s has to follow
“know your customer” rules, so the DAO needs
to partner with an LLC. Two members of the DAO
step up to form the LLC and bridge the crypto and
traditional finance worlds. It’s now Monday, and
things are really picking up steam. Ten thousand
people are chatting in the Discord. The media
starts catching on. Packy McCormick writes a blog,
then CNBC covers it. Donations start flowing.
Tuesday leads to more big names signing on. Chris
Dixon and other A16Z folks are supporting the
project now. On Wednesday, they break $20 million
raised. It starts looking like this might actually
happen. Thursday is auction day, and people are
absolutely stoked. The DAO has over $40 million
dollars now. It’s chaos in the Discord, no one
knows who’s representing the DAO. Clearly both
bidders really want this. Brooke Lampley places
the winning bid at $41 million dollars, but no
one knows who she’s bidding for. DAO backers are
claiming victory, but slowly, the truth leaks out.
The DAO lost. And the winner is revealed. It’s Ken
Griffin, the founder of Citadel and arch-nemesis
of the WallStreetBets reddit. A crushing defeat.
The story of the ConstitutionDAO is useful because
it touches so many different aspects of the
current web3 landscape. So let’s go through the
good parts of this, then talk about some of the
bad parts, and finally close on the ugly, because
it gets really ugly here. First up, the good.
Well, it’s the Constitution, what’s not to like?
It’s an extremely meaningful historical document
and the DAO only had two rules for what they
were going to do with it. It had to be displayed
publicly, and it had to have a plaque next to
it that mentioned the ConstitutionDAO’s website.
That’s a noble goal, and it’s a big part of what
led to the massive surge in support. The team
also did a great job of making it clear that they
weren’t in this for financial gain. Even though
they could have easily given themselves some
tokens for free at the start of the project,
they didn’t, which helped build trust in the
community. Now, to be fair, there’s still a world
where the core contributors wind up benefitting
from the project. The team was planning on
submitting a proposal for compensation after the
auction that would have been voted on by the DAO,
but that certainly seems reasonable to me. And a
lot of the team members had other web3 projects,
and a high profile story like this could draw
attention to what they're working on. But again,
that’s totally reasonable. This approach led to
a very positive community developing around the
project. Although I didn’t contribute to the
project, I was in the Discord and could see
that everyone was just having fun and excited to
be a part of a cool story. No one was trying to
inflate expectations, and the core team was very
clear that the DAO was merely a governance token
and did not represent real ownership in the
Constitution. Packy McCormick put it really
well in his blog post when he said “If
you want to contribute, you should think
about it as purchasing a keepsake as opposed to
investing in an asset.” Even with this caveat,
I think the fact that money donated to the
ConstitutionDAO was going to fund the purchase
of a real physical item is important here. Unlike
previous crypto projects, the ConstitutionDAO is
very easy to understand, even for people
who are new to crypto. At this point,
most people understand what an NFT is, they’ve
seen the crazy jpegs selling for millions
and heard about massive Sothebys auctions, but not
everyone agrees that these NFTs have value. The
Constitution on the other hand has centuries of
history behind it and could actually generate cash
flow, at least in theory. Although this wasn’t
the plan, some museums do charge entrance fees,
so it’s not crazy to come up with some sort of
fundamental value based on traditional financial
modeling. Even though the project didn’t
pan out as planned, it definitely served
as a good educational tool for sparking interest
in DAOs. The idea of a Decentralized Autonomous
Organization is still very new to most people,
but the ConstitutionDAO helped spread the idea
that lots of people could come together quickly
online to crowdfund a specific goal. And unlike
traditional crowdfunding, DAOs have a built-in
voting mechanism. It’s still unclear where these
DAOs will go, or how useful they will be in the
future, but more people are aware of how they
work, and I think that’s a win for the team
behind this project. Obviously the hope here
was to win the auction and propel the DAO into
the mainstream zeitgeist, and it doesn’t look
like that will happen. But it’s still remarkable
that this project was able to break into the
mainstream media in just a few days. Crypto
broadly has been a hot topic for years now,
but most of the attention comes back to price
movements. Everytime bitcoin hits a new all-time
high there will undoubtedly be a press cycle
covering it, and that’s fine if you own Bitcoin,
but I don’t think it really moves the needle
where it’s needed most, the developer community.
The ConstitutionDAO represents a step forward
precisely because there wasn’t an expectation
of massive overnight gain, so one of the few ways
to get more involved was to actually contribute to
the project in some way. If you’re a proponent
of crypto, this seems like a good development,
the ConstitutionDAO was basically a massive stress
test of the current web3 infrastructure and it
clearly exposed a bunch of areas for development.
Most of the problems, which we will get to in a
minute, do have solutions, and they are now much
easier to see for interested developers. Last, but
certainly not least, it is extremely good that no
money was stolen here. Crypto is still very much
a wild west, and fortunes are made and lost every
day. The very first DAO, which was appropriately
named just “The DAO” raised $150 million dollars
before quickly getting hacked back in 2016. Even
though web3 projects can offer very high levels
of security, there are still a ton of bad actors
out there who can scam people, but that didn’t
happen here. Even though they lost the auction,
supporters will get their money back, and that’s
a good result all things considered. The stakes
were clearly pretty high with tens of millions
of dollars flowing into the DAO, but the team
handled things responsibly and kept communication
flowing. But now, we have to turn to the bad side
of this project, and we should probably start
with the actual structure of the DAO, because
it’s extremely convoluted. Web3 projects tend to
work best when they are off in their own little
pristine walled gardens. The world of traditional
finance is extremely messy and highly regulated,
but wading through all of that was unavoidable for
this project. Let me walk you through how money
was actually going to flow from individuals to
the original owner of the constitution: Step one:
a contributor goes to a cryptocurrency exchange
like Coinbase and buys ether with U.S Dollars from
their bank account. Step two: they now send that
ether from Coinbase to a wallet like Metamask.
Step three: They use metamask to send ether to
the ConstitutionDAO project, which is hosted
by a crowdfunding platform called Juicebox. Step
four: all of the ether donations are collected in
a multi-sig wallet, which requires agreement
from 13 different team members in order to
move that money further. Step five: because
Sotheby’s can’t work directly with the DAO,
a Delaware LLC with just two signatories, has
to interface with the auction house. Step six:
The LLC would orchestrate the transfer to
Sotheby’s in the event that they won the auction.
That’s a remarkably complex process for
something pretty simple at its core.
We’re just talking about a bunch of people
pooling their resources to buy a single object,
this shouldn’t be so complicated, and yet it is,
because web3 is so new and best practices are
still being developed on the fly. One of the big
benefits of crypto projects is decentralization
and the ConstitutionDAO was going to allow
everyone who donated to vote on where to display
the constitution in proportion to the amount
they paid. The tokens they issued would allow
these votes to take place without needing any
single person to be trusted to count the votes.
This is a great use for crypto and it wouldn’t
have any issues if there wasn’t a physical asset
involved. The problem is that the further you get
from the blockchain, the more centralization is
required to move things forward quickly, and at a
certain point, the ConstitutionDAO wound up in a
situation where you basically had to trust that
the two people responsible for the Delaware LLC
would do the right thing. I think these issues can
be solved though, especially with a long enough
time horizon. It’s remarkable that the team was
able to do as much as they did in just seven days,
and I really have no doubt that we will see
much stronger patterns develop in the next
few years here. But we still need to talk about
the most obvious bad outcome here: they lost. The
DAO originally thought that raising $20 million
dollars would be enough, since that’s how much
experts thought this copy of the constitution
was worth. The DAO wound up raising more than
twice that much, but they still couldn’t win, and
a big reason why is because the funding total was
public. Given that the maximum possible bid was
known to everyone, the seller of the constitution,
meaning the person who owned it and put it up for
auction, could bid against the DAO directly to
drive up the price. If the seller knows that the
DAO is willing to pay up to $40 million dollars,
they will bid up to $39 million just to get the
maximum payday from the DAO. Even if the DAO does
win the auction, the more money they raise, the
more expensive the final price gets. Now, to be
fair, it doesn’t look like the seller was bidding
on the Constitution at all. Ken Griffin is just a
multi-billionaire and was able to outbid the DAO
directly. But it’s always a bad idea to show your
cards before you have to, and that’s exactly
what the ConstitutionDAO did here. Even still,
in the long term, there could be a solution to
this problem. There is a branch of crypto called
zero-knowledge proofs that could obfuscate
the exact amount of money raised by the DAO,
while still giving Sotheby's confirmation
that the DAO could fund their current bid.
It’s complex stuff, and it’s not going to be
implemented next week, but it’s theoretically
possible and would make a lot of sense for
the next project of this kind. The last bad
outcome from this project has been a bit of a
punchline on Twitter: transaction fees. Because
of all the interest in web3 projects, the ethereum
blockchain has become very expensive to work with.
Everytime you go to execute a transaction, you’ll
usually get hit with a “gas fee” somewhere between
$20 and $100 dollars. Even though the DAO lost the
auction, everyone that contributed still had to
pay gas fees to transfer their ether into the DAO.
Some people were estimating that the total cost
of transaction fees could be as high as $5 million
dollars, but it looks like it was closer to $880k.
That’s still a ton of money though and it
doesn’t really fit with the long-term promise
of cryptocurrency. Worse still, everyone who put
money in, would now be hit with more gas fees on
the way out as they requested refunds. The median
contribution size was only $200, so lots of people
wound up paying nearly 50% in transaction fees.
Everyone in the crypto community is aware of this
problem though and they know that this will hurt
adoption if it’s not fixed. The Ethereum team is
working on eth2.0 to lower these fees, and other
blockchains like Solana already offer low fees
and similar functionality. So transaction fees are
unlikely to be a major problem in the long term,
even if they won’t be resolved overnight. But now
we have to discuss the really ugly truth about
this project. The core concept here is remarkably
simple. We’re just talking about a bunch of people
chipping in to buy something expensive, it’s not
complicated. And yet there still doesn’t seem to
be an easy way to get this done. Why is that? Part
of this has to do with trade-offs. There are good
reasons for know your customer and anti-money
laundering laws, and it’s also important to
protect people from scams, but it seems ridiculous
to me that this is still so difficult in the year
2021. We’re not talking about curing cancer here,
or building a mars colony, it’s really just moving
some numbers around that represent value. When I
think about the future, I still envision all the
classic sci-fi elements: flying cars, interstellar
travel, immersive virtual environments. These
crypto projects are a reminder that we still have
a remarkably messy financial system and dealing
with that takes time. I do think this is important
work, and I think that the ConstitutionDAO could
lead to some meaningful innovation, but it’s
still a bit sad that we have to spend so
much time untangling messy systems, just to move
forward. I’m definitely going to do more research
on crypto and Web3, so if you’d like to follow
along, just drop your email at johncoogan.com,
and please check out this recommended video, the
YouTube algorithm thinks you’ll really like it.